daniel jeremiah my draft compadre who
will be sitting next to me in cleveland
ohio for an insane amount of time at the
end of next month joining me here
on the rich eisen show fresh off of
calling the zack wilson pro day live on
nfl network
on friday how are you dj i'm doing great
rich are you refreshed are you are you
ready for this uh stretch run we're
headed towards
i am not cramping how does that sound
i don't plan on cramping i plan on being
fully hydrated and getting ready to go
uh literally and figuratively my run is
gonna happen next month
i have uh i've got a caper i'm trying to
pull off
to make it uh make it as special as ever
so
that's coming down the pike too i'm
ready i'm ready i can't i can't wait to
to learn of the details
that will be coming um and in the
meantime so
um did somebody get in your ear if you
will during the pro day say you have no
idea what just happened or do you have
any idea what was happening you're
looking down your phone during zach
wilson's pro day knowing that everything
had been
sort of turned upside down in a way so i
heard i heard from a little birdie
uh that morning that something was gonna
happen
so i knew that uh that there was gonna
be a trade
it was gonna involve somebody moving up
i didn't know who it was um
but i kind of was on alert so i was one
of those deals and you've been there
rich where you're where you're on air
and you've got your computer and you're
just hitting
you know refresh refresh refresh and
just hoping
hoping that's going to happen during
this two-hour window where we're on
because there's nothing more fun
and so boom this thing happens and so
you digest it while you're watching
zach you know warm up and then
just as you start to get comfortable
with that rhett is talking as the host
and and so he's watching
right here yep he's talking about
this trade with with miami in san
francisco
and i'm on my computer and all of a
sudden i see it come across from the
eagles official account that they've
just
moved back from six to twelve and so
it was one of the fields you like it
says blue check mark but like just
clicking on the
clicking on it making sure like this is
now i'm not getting you know screwed on
this thing
so while rhett's talking i turn around
my
laptop rich because we're sitting far
apart you know with the way things are
yep
and i'm trying to slide my laptop across
the table so that he can see that this
eagle tree is happening
and so he ended up breaking that uh just
reading that right off the laptop
and off we went it was it was fun man
well it sure looks like
speaking of refresh san francisco hit
refresh
so let's start there um
because when trades like this happen
clearly we can't put
names to fill in the blanks yet but we
can guess
um yeah what do you make of san
francisco moving up to three
and for who daniel jeremiah
well i definitely think they they felt
like um they needed better than jimmy
garoppolo to make such a
aggressive costly move um with what they
gave up to go up to three
and they obviously have a love
of three quarterbacks so let's assume
as most knew that that trevor lawrence
and zach wilson are two of the three
that they are
excited about we try and figure out who
that third guy
is and when it happened immediately
my mind went to trey lance as somebody
that i thought would be a fun
fit there um and i'm thinking trey lance
versus justin fields i can make a case
justin fields would be an exciting pick
there
so i'm processing and i'm thinking well
wait a second trey lance has already had
his pro day
and i had heard there's always you hear
all these stories behind the scenes but
i had heard
look the niners didn't send their
decision makers to north dakota state
for that pro day because they want to
kind of lay in the weeds on trey lance
but
um you know that's why they did it but
you're gonna get the video of the pro
day they'll see everything um but i'm
like okay treelance's pro days already
happened so
they could be kind of towards the finish
line of his evaluation and have the
conviction to make a trade like this
justin fields hasn't had his pro day yet
so if you were going to trade up with
him in mind i would think you'd want to
wait until his pro day just to make sure
he's healthy and throwing the ball
fine and give you a little more uh
comfort to make that type of a bold move
so i'm like okay i'm leaning towards
tray lance
then you talk to people in the know
around the league rich
and they're like i'm telling you this is
this is for the bama quarterback this is
not
this is not trey lancer justin field
this is this is for mac
uh for mac jones so uh and i heard it
from a lot of people and i think look
when you see
you know chris sims as well and it's
easy to connect the dots with him and
kyle and their friendship that that he
kind of hopped aboard that train
um that's kind of where we are well i
mean
yeah uh okay if it's mac jones
i i imagine the niners decided
sitting at where they were
wasn't good enough right like sitting at
12 wasn't good enough for mack jones
they weren't gonna
risk it they could have maybe
moved up the i guess they figured that
mac jones could be gone
at four and and for atlanta like so
and i understand that that draft boards
change clearly
between now and at the end of april but
they caught wind like you know what we
can't run the risk that arthur smith's
gonna love mack jones as much as
he thinks he's his tannehill or
something like that and let's go get
like we got to go to three
right i mean what do you think my my
take on it rich is two parts
number one it's um you know john lynch
is there but
kyle has has the juice right so
kyle and when you have coaches that have
the power
on decisions like these a lot of times
they're not as
not as worried about the cost as much as
they're worried about
getting their guy and the extreme
example
is look what happened in houston when
with bill o'brien
you know you just say i want i want
laramie council get him what i don't
care what it costs just go get him
and then on the other hand you have an
asset in in hopkins which if you canvass
the league
and feel out the market the value you'd
say okay man he's probably worth a lot
more than arizona just offered us but
now we're gonna move on from him so just
trade him get rid of him
but um i i think that's what happened
sometimes with with coach run decisions
that they can
maybe not care so much about the you
know what the market says
just determined i like this guy i'm
gonna go get him and the other thing i
would say is
in talking to people during the time of
the senior bowl
uh the fact that pepper was down there
as an owner which you rarely see in
going back to the days when you were
calling that game rich
you don't remember seeing owners on the
sidelines at the senior bowl right even
though mac jones didn't play in the game
um it was kind of widely thought that he
was going down there to be around mack
that that would be a play for them
potentially at number eight and the last
thing you want to do if you really think
that that's the answer
you don't want to get in the bidding war
with the team that has a higher pick
than you because you're going to lose
you're referring to david tepper the
owner of the carolina panthers i've got
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show
stands to reason they knocked on the jet
store first though right
daniel what do you think um i i i don't
i don't know that that is the case
i i think that's been assumed i don't
know that to be
a fact okay so then let's get out of the
news and information business and get
back into the evaluation business
um the tea leaves are that the jets
um clearly are gonna take zach wilson
now right i mean
because you have to you have to assume
and i know what assuming really means
potentially but you have to assume that
the organization that used a third round
pick
to in the trade with miami that they got
because they lost robert sala to the
jets to be their head coach
that they would at least have the knock
on the door
to make sure that they're that they're
doing their due diligence just in case
the jets go out i mean
the odds that joe douglas calls up um
you know john lynch said what gives we
could have got
we could have done something you know i
mean like it just while they're standing
watching zach wilson
light it up in his pro day this means
that it's zach wilson to the jets
right well i mean i think we've been
we've been talking about this since uh
january and
it was my opinion that zach wilson was
going to be the second pick in january
and
march 29th and i'll be shocked if he
isn't the pick with the jets at two i i
would be shocked
what do you look like to you in person
it was fun to watch man
uh it was really fun look to me pro days
rich
you don't want you don't want to make
more of them than they are i get that
but to me you can accomplish two things
in a pro day
number one you can fill in the gaps from
things we didn't get a chance to see you
do so maybe you're an
offense where they don't throw the ball
down the field maybe there's not as many
drive throws maybe you know
as mac jones tried to do it his product
he didn't move around a lot so they try
and feature some movement
so that's one thing just fill in the
gaps the other thing you can accomplish
is you can show off like it's show and
tell right this is look at all the stuff
i can do
well when you look at zach i i've seen
him do everything on the video i've seen
him make every type of throw on schedule
off schedule on the move right left
you know a lot you know power throws
touch throws deep balls i've seen him do
all that so he didn't really have any
gaps to fill in
so it basically set this up to be a just
kind of a show-off
session and it was fun to watch i
enjoyed the heck out of it i i think
hopefully people could could feel that
from me watching it i would just
it was fun man anytime you watch
somebody that's great at something it'd
be like if you're watching steph curry
go out and shoot a bunch of threes
um i enjoyed it i don't get the people
that are cynical
and don't want to enjoy something like
that it was fun it was fun for me
well i mean that throw where he drifted
to his left and i think
i think you were busy you know going
about
down the road of byu versus coastal
carolina and then you had to sort of
stop your story you know
and go oh my god that was ridiculous i
mean that went viral i mean that got
picked up everywhere
and we saw that but you know that said
when you say that you
you know pro day is set up uh to have a
kid show off
his skills and talents and and just have
a little bit of fun like that
you know ryan day's going to set up
stuff like that for justin fields right
so or justin fields people will do that
his pro day is tuesday if i'm not
mistaken what
how how might that shuffle things up do
you think well you know
there's the old phrase right i'll have
my people call your people well
justin and zach have the same people
john beck who ran the uh
zach wilson pro day is going to be
running the justin fields project hey
carl
uh so i talked to him this morning and
they're gonna you'll see a lot of
similar things
he's gonna uh he's got a chance to show
off himself
so okay so now that we've just thought
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show now that we've
we've dissected the big uh
move from 12 to two up to three uh
49ers dolphins trade what did you make
of the dolphins moving up to six
and the eagles moving down to 12. what
are your thoughts on that daniel
jeremiah
well i think uh a couple things on the
dolphins that they accomplished
um number one where they ultimately
ended up is in position to get a premier
target right whether that's where that's
pitts or jamar chase
you know devonta smith or waddle however
those are the big four targets
they're going to be able to get a big
time weapon to help
evaluate to us so that accomplished that
the other thing it accomplished is
they accumulated some some more uh you
know tokens
i guess you could say in and and drafts
beyond this one
which will will live that leave them
some flexibility
with the whole desean watson situation
because if
you know we were looking at this a week
ago we'd say man i don't know that
anything can happen with deshaun watson
given
the current circumstances and if you
look at the dolphins
if they are going to be able to come
together with houston
uh on a trade the majority of their
chips are in this draft so
once we get past this draft it's hard to
match them up for a trade because the
dolphins just don't have as many assets
as you would need
um and so now what they've done is
they've collected another first round
pick
in next year's draft they've given
themselves flexibility
to extend this to allow this thing with
desean watson
to play out so that once the draft this
21 draft ends
their their uh opportunity for deshawn
watson does not expire they can play the
long game here
ah because i thought this would mean
that they're in on tua
right i think i i think it gives them an
opportunity with what they've done
to not select in the draft a replacement
for tua but to support him where we can
potentially look at him with more
weapons which gives us an evaluation
but i also think if this thing with the
sean watson were to clear up
and it clears up over the summer they
have the chips in place to make that
trade right then and there
because they've they've gotten more
draft capital down the line
yeah oh my word so the what about the
eagles as you know
uh people in philadelphia are kind of
like well
we could have had one of those top
playmakers that you mentioned those four
playmakers
for for jalen hurts and instead they
move down and they put more capital into
next year's draft in which they could
wind up with three number one
yeah uh first three first-round draft
choices
what do you make of philadelphia's
maneuvering
i i think it was it was pretty smart
because i
i believe when you look at the needs of
the roster
um to me you know i i think everybody's
assuming they're going to go get a
player to surround
uh and properly evaluate jalen hurts
and if they would have stuck at six i i
had made the strong case you take kyle
pitt to be there he's the best player
he's going to be the best player
available
um you take him but what they've done is
they've kind of they've kind of
couched everything here and said okay
we're going to go back to 12. to me it
points to either the best pass rusher or
the best corner that's where the value
is where they're picking their 12.
um and then they have like you said
three ones
potentially next year so you're going to
get a look-see here at jalen hurts for a
year
with a full off-season in a full
training camp pre-season all that stuff
you're going to get a chance to evaluate
him and if for some reason
it goes if it goes well man you're
loaded with ammunition to build around
him next year and if it doesn't go well
you're loaded with ammunition to go find
another quarterback so
that's what that looks like to me from
the outside okay am i am i missing
anything is there another
domino or ripple in this pond domino
that tumbled with this trade on friday
again you kind of threw me for one
with saying you know how the dolphins
amassed more picks
in the coming years gives them
flexibility to wait out what happens
with desean watson in houston that now
suddenly
maybe the draft isn't a deadline a go or
no go for
houston and deshaun watson that that it
could now be training camp potentially
because
uh the dolphins now have the same
package that
could have been delivered to houston
before the draft they have that
before this season for next year's
drafts you kind of threw me for one
right there is there anything else we're
not
we're not seeing we're not thinking of
right here well i mean i
i'd like to contribute you know at least
one topic for a follow-up segment on the
rich i didn't show when i come on
richard
it seems like there's definitely going
to be an
endless pit of stuff to talk about for
this draft but
i'm just wondering if if there are
anything is that you know
that jimmy g i guess is potentially
gonna be the guy unless they take mac
jones he would be the most i would think
pro ready because he played at alabama
and he's got he's got more
reps at it than justin fields and trey
lance right i mean
what do you think of that yeah i mean
you know it's interesting because steve
white um the great steve white after
this came down he was there so he went
up and and talked to kyle shanahan and
came right back on the air and said
look they kyle said jimmy's a part of
our plan so
when i heard that i thought well if
jimmy's a part of your plan then that
points to
you know trey lance or justin fields
because you don't have to play those
guys
right away they might not be ready right
now whereas mac the feeling the feeling
is that he'd be ready to step in and
play and having mac
and having jimmy on the same team
doesn't make any sense um so that that
threw me for a loop but then there's
also i mean what what is kyle
going to say you know jimmy's still on
the team so you
you know you kind of he hadn't spoken to
him yet either i guess he spoke to him
on friday after the pro day
it seems like yeah so i don't i don't
know what you could say otherwise there
so
it's still um it's going to be
fascinating i think we kind of we think
we know what's going to happen there but
you never know and then it gets to
atlanta where everybody has said
or a license here but a lot of people
have said well they you know with this
mac ryan deal they really are kind of
into him now for a couple more years
uh with the salary cap but but i've
talked to a couple general managers that
said look they had to do that to get
under the salary cap they didn't have a
choice
so i would not rule out a quarterback uh
there and he wouldn't have to play right
away
which again when you look at trey lance
and justin fields could be a perfect
situation for them to uh
to sit behind matt ryan for a minute so
i wouldn't i wouldn't rule them out
and then to me the the quarterback
domino that's left is sam
is sam darnold and i look at carolina
and i look at denver as two teams who
have kind of let it be known
um that they they're in the quarterback
business so you know does sam go to one
of those teams
and if he you know the team that doesn't
get him does that motivate them to try
and
to try and move up because if mac if
matt goes three rich
now we're talking about there's a real
chance we could go you know one two
three four
six or if if the bengals get out one two
three four five
with quarterbacks it's gonna be nuts
yeah and then the panthers and the
broncos choose
eight and nine um and you know this is
going to be my 17th draft that i host
for nfl network and
through the years with mayok and you
i've picked up a couple things
um certainly lately you know late in the
latest draft uh
for it the uh the drafting of kyler
murray and i'm sitting there wondering
why
why is rosen still on the team and you
know
um you you say to me during a commercial
break you can't
trade the guy until you have the other
guy in hand you know and mayok was just
telling me the same thing for all those
years but i got caught up in the whole
rosen of it all and he got traded the
next night is it possible
then daniel that the jets draft zach
wilson second and while the clock is
moving
towards eight and nine overall for the
panthers and broncos that
darnold gets moved in that interim
period
dj i think i think that this is
what a great friendship is all about i
feel like i delivered you a little
present and i feel like in turn you have
delivered me one because i didn't really
think about that
um from the standpoint of waiting until
they're on the clock so i'm gonna write
that one down file it away there you go
i'm going to claim it i'm going to claim
it as my own do it i want to when i'm on
path to the draft later this afternoon
do it because i'm trying to figure out
like when
how does what's the mechanics of this
for joe douglas to make as much hay as
he possibly can
with a quarterback that the rest of the
league knows he's got to unload
you know well i think there's uh what is
it ebay that has a buy now price yes
right
yes so you get the buy now price from a
team that you love you take it right now
if you don't have your buy now price
then it's a then it's a bid and we wait
till we get to the draft and
let it play out and then you treat like
zack wilson to mix mixed sports like
andre drummond you just remove him from
society and put him in bubble wrap and
say you don't do a damn thing until
the draft hits right i mean if right
yeah yeah you you're always i mean yeah
if you do a deal right now again
there's always risk with everything so
you just you got to hope that zach
wilson is uh
is on his couch and just taking care of
himself yes and looks both ways before
crossing the street and just
basically netflix and chill man you know
as much as somebody from byu could
yeah if you're going to go for a jog
make sure the headband does not come
down over your eyes keep that thing up
on your head there dj thanks for the
call really appreciate it you
when's the uh the move the sticks with
you and uh and bucky brooks coming out
to discuss all this
yeah we just had a fun chat about it so
it should be coming out any uh anytime
now so be on the lookout for that later
okay let's do that dj thanks for the
call really appreciate it thanks buddy
you got it and get daniel jeremiah and
bucky brooks move the sticks podcast for
more on that
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here